françois pignon ou encore le grand blond
pierre richard est plutôt connue comme
vedette comique du cinéma français mais
c'est en tant que vigneron qui était
présent à magny les hameaux samedi 26
septembre
il est venu dédicacer ses bouteilles de
vin du domaine de l'évêque situé dans le
languedoc dont il est propriétaire
depuis 1986 c'est une des places
importantes dans ma vie et le cinéma
évidemment peut-être numéro un quand
même mais
j'ai une deuxième passion une deuxième
l'intérêt pour le vin parce que ça
finalement c'est un peu comme le cinéma
l'objectif du cinéma du vin c'est donner
du plaisir à des gens me fait rire ou
les émouvoir le vin je dis pas que 20
pour le faire les fait rire encore
qu'après la deuxième bouteille on
commence à l'école et l'acteur a fait
des émules
ils sont venus nombreux faire dédicacer
leurs bouteilles et chacun avait sa
petite raison je suis pas une grande
amatrice de vin évidemment mais c'est
surtout pour d'acteurs parce que j'adore
kerichard moi j'aime le vin j'aime la
gastronomie et donc voilà donc forcément
ça m'arrivait de goûter ces vins sont
tombés amoureux de certains écrivent et
je suis venu chercher près de 600
bouteilles pendant le confinement et
plus de 1800 en une journée à magny les
hameaux le 22 pierre richard a su
convaincre les papilles